so today we wanted to bring in
lieutenant governor of Florida about
that particular story shipping illegal
immigrants to Martha's Vineyard under
the guidance of Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis and we're glad to have
lieutenant governor Jeanette Nunez on
the program this morning thanks for
being with us lieutenant governor
good morning thank you for having me
uh let's follow up on the story that has
dominated the news the last several days
um illegal immigrants shipped to
Martha's Vineyard and then the ensuing
Fallout I would love to ask you two
things a what do you expect was
accomplished and B will there be more
flights under the direction of Florida
sending illegal immigrants to other
parts of the country
foreign
well again thank you for having me and
what we've accomplished is actually
doing the job that President Biden
should be doing Florida is not a
sanctuary State we've made that very
clear under this relocation program
which the governor got approved by the
legislature and let me add by many if
not all Democrats that are part of the
legislature approved it what we've done
is we've been able to protect Florida we
are now unfortunately because of the
crisis at the border two million people
crossing illegally more than 8 000 a day
and that's not even counting the
godaways Florida has now become
essentially a Border Town and so because
the governor has made it clear that
Florida is not a sanctuary State we've
been able to relocate voluntarily might
I add these individuals that have
crossed illegally that have decided that
they want to go to greener pastures and
it's only at the point when they arrive
at the doorstep of the Rich and Famous
that the left starts to complain and so
their virtue signaling their hypocrisy
is on Full display for the entirety of
America to see they were flown to a
sanctuary Island where that Sanctuary
Island only tolerated them for 44 hours
before sending them calling the Army and
taking them off the island do you
anticipate sending additional flights to
Martha's Vineyard and anything you can
you can tell us about that
the governor
uh that that very thing that he will be
sending additional individuals to other
locations we received 12 million dollars
and he made it very clear that he was
going to spend every penny of those 12
million dollars to protect Floridians
because what we're seeing is that
fentanyl overdoses are the number one
killer of individuals ages 18 to 45.
human trafficking is a major concern for
our state we have had State Strike Force
teams with law enforcement here in our
state and they have interdicted and they
have been able to arrest individuals 38
charges of human smuggling 58 charges of
drug trafficking this is something that
should concern every single Floridian
every single American and the governor
is going to use every tool at his
disposal to address this crisis because
the federal government and Joe Biden
refused to do so lieutenant governor I
want to talk to you about another angle
of this story so you know we kind of
have been here saying oh well you know
laughing about the racism of the rich
white people on the island who by the
way there's incredible footage on the
internet of them cheering and singing as
they bust off you know the Hispanic uh
you know illegal immigrants off the
island and over to the military bases
Pete explained but it's interesting to
me because one of the most famous the
most famous resident Barack Obama
Michelle Obama have said nothing about
rich white ladies singing and screaming
te amo as these Hispanics are LED off
the island and I think it's interesting
because it points to the real divide in
this country it is not about race it's
about class this was one of the most
elitist moments ever captured on film
and I cannot believe that she has not
responded Michelle Obama what do you say
to that
again I think that they just continue to
show the hypocrisy they lecture us they
lecture Republicans and red States and
they call us inhumane when they are in
fact the ones that are demonstrating how
inhumane they actually are President
Biden was quick to fly illegals under
the cloak of Darkness into different
areas but the minute again the minute
they arrive in an area in which you've
got a bunch of Rich folks that live out
the American Dream On full display what
what we see from the Obamas and the rest
of the radical left is hypocrisy the
same thing we had to deal with during
covid rules for thee but not for me just
to illustrate Rachel's point I want to
share with you and the audience a couple
of now deleted tweets this is from NBC
News Florida Governor DeSantis sending
Asylum Seekers to Martha's Vineyard is
like quote me taking my trash out and
just driving to different areas where I
live and just throwing my trash there a
founding member of a foundation which
helps refugees reportedly says pairing
legal immigrants to trash and then of
course Jill Biden made this famous
analogy
the distinct as the bogudas of the Bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of Miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in San Antonio
too much it's too much it's um it's such
a wonderful illustration of what you and
Rachel are both talking about but
lieutenant governor I wanted to actually
give you an opportunity to respond to
some of the things so there are various
accusations of course you've seen it
kidnapping
um human trafficking but I do I am
curious about the details so I know that
these 50 illegal immigrants came from
Texas through the coordination with
Florida you're being accused of lying to
the immigrants illegal immigrants about
where they were headed that's one of the
things in addition to the the you know
kidnapping charges that are being thrown
out is that true under what what was the
my understanding is most of these all of
this is under voluntary status when it
comes to these immigrants headed north
how was this coordinated
well those accusations are categorically
false I think everyone that has some
semblance of Common Sense can understand
that this was a voluntary program again
voluntary meaning the individual the
illegal immigrant had to acquiesce there
was consent forms there was information
provided a map I understand of Martha's
Vineyard
um so all of this was done with full
consent full awareness there was no
lying there was no duping this was not
like Biden's program of flying people in
the cloak of Darkness not informing the
uh the the government not informing us
when we've requested information we've
had to sue the Biden Administration for
their Catch and Release policy so all
this was done absolutely under the
sunshine if you will with ample
information and these people opted to go
there they came into Florida and from
there they went on to their final
destination and again this was the
governor said very clearly this was a
tool that we had on our disposal
something that we got approved back in
March so now all of a sudden they come
to the realization that for once a
governor will do what he says and say
what he does yeah you know yesterday we
had I know Florida is not on the border
but as you pointed out it has become a
border state in a Border Town like many
others because of these policies we have
the lieutenant governor of Texas on
yesterday and we pressed him about the
Declaration of uh an invasion in Texas
and a constitutional prerogative that he
could the state of Texas could have we
had Ken cuccinelli on the program today
that knows all about that and said a lot
of states have shown a willingness to go
support Texas should they make that
declaration and our understanding based
on Ken cuccinelli is that Texas could
without the legislature effectively
declare an invasion and then have new
Constitutional Powers how would Florida
treat that if Texas were to say now it's
time to do some enforcement ourselves
well as you pointed again Florida's in a
border state but because of the Reckless
policies the chaos at the border we have
essentially become one so we have been
extremely supportive of our friends in
Texas and Arizona the governor early on
sent the National Guard to assist Texas
when the crisis was beginning to unfold
we have of course uh offered support we
will continue to offer support but if
that declaration is made I'm certain
that the governor will take that under
consideration and see what Florida can
do again to not only address the crisis
but to prevent Floridians from being
exposed to the effects of illegal
immigration one of the issues that we
are concerned about is the fact that
there are criminal illegals
um people that potentially are on the
terrorist watch list people that are
drug smugglers human traffickers people
that have heinous backgrounds criminal
backgrounds these people are entering
our communities our neighborhoods we
have prided our Administration our first
term on being a Law and Order
Administration we have done so many
things to support our men and women in
blue and this is just one more example
of why the federal government does not
care about law enforcement they do not
care about securing the Border all they
want to do is virtue signal and continue
to ignore this crisis you know when you
have the vice president saying that the
border is secure I mean I don't think
there is a better example of her being
completely out of touch with reality
just to follow up on Pete's question
um you've made the comparison several
times and said Florida is a border state
theoretically as this has been laid out
to us this is not an immigration issue
it is an invasion as declared under
States powers under acts of War to
remove people from your state is that
something that the governor of Florida
would consider is no requirement that
you exist on the Mexican border to
declare that invasion you have made the
analogy you are a border state you have
an illegal immigration crisis although
they may be coming through other states
instead of flying them to Martha's
Vineyard would Governor DeSantis
consider removing illegal immigrants
from their place of origin
well not having spoken to the governor
specifically about that I don't want to
speak for him but I will tell you the
governor is extremely he's shown he's
extremely tough on on these instances
he's shown that he is insisting uh that
the federal government do its job we
have done so many things uh and even the
state of Texas having to take on that
burden 2.5 million dollars a week that
they're spending over there there's
residence taxpayers the governor I think
would look at every opportunity uh to
support and and I think that that's
something he would consider lieutenant
governor I want to thank you for joining
us today and also if you would extend as
a Hispanic woman my thanks to the
governor for using his powers to expose
the hypocrisy of the rich ladies on the
island of Martha's Vineyard who
apparently only like Hispanics who work
in their homes so appreciate this very
much lieutenant governor thank you thank
you
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and
I'm Ainsley Earhart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis